[Music]
we had that one video on the Zen like a
lot of people Zen is turn into like this
a
relaxation it's not really what it's
supposed to be anymore in
modern Zen modern Buddhism
but you can't reverse engineer it you
have a mood drop you already know this
is alchemical
energetic just got to be it's not about
relaxing it's not about feeling the
intellect with something it's not about
intention okay and see same thing in
iido there's a hand shape there's an arm
shape and you don't with it because
it's working through mudra as well and
the mudra Works how the mudra works I
don't know how it works I I don't think
there's a scientific reason for why it
works but empirically it works and since
we're not academics and we're not
scientists we don't care the why
we only care about the
how
okay so um you got to keep your
handshake and we've defined things so I
have we've already defined that and we
know we have the inward spiral and we
have the outer spiral and we gave you
clear markers on it which is that the on
the in spiral the
wrist and the elbow are in a different
part of the Spiral meaning they're not
on a circle where they make a
curvature at the same
time the RIS go go first the elbow
starts it afterwards inward spiral on
the outward spiral the elbow goes first
the wrist per second okay so hence we
don't have these shapes we don't have
that
shape we don't have this
shape okay got the
idea um we don't have this
shape those aren't the shapes we
use um try to understand in this drill
you're doing the the energenic work
you're working on that fighting is going
to change what you do if I'm if I'm
grabbing him then I'm not a loud on if
I'm punching him I'm not a loud on if
I'm doing the inward elbow I'm not on
the spiral do you do you guys understand
that but we're doing an energetic TR so
you are constantly working on these
things you're never going to
go all pushing on the center
always getting them to rotate around
each other whichever it is this way I'm
not going like this I'm going like
that you can look like you can but not
really you're pulling him you're pulling
him you can feel it you feel
it I put the elbow in I'm not pulling
him I'm pushing
him same thing here if I'm over here
like this
and this goes out without the elbow
wrist rotating around each other this is
different boom boom the forearm is doing
the linear part of what you're thinking
the Palm heel is doing the forearm
elbows doing it boom okay got it so even
though you smell them you got them you
smell it you still are going to do elbow
in elbow in wrist in you're still going
to do it okay try it again
now wrist in coming you had wrist elbow
alignment you don't want wrist
elbow use your forearm to push
are you're thinking two
dimensional you're thinking you're
thinking that this one is push stay
there please that this one is pushing
like
this so you spear your hand through like
that but if you keep the El if you keep
the wrist
turning then the elbow push it you see
that so you're not going here ins
spearing his the hand through the grip
the elbow is turning keep your
grip got it h go
we're not throwing you just aren't
committing do the same
try to get the seizure not the external
yield se but SE is an obstruction
this don't smell it do it
feel
that so you're here and he's he's up
there so you're trying to you see but if
you just go
in what you think instead of going
here you just go out
see okay chase the VRA not not what
happening in there
elbow in
let your let your forearm elbow do the
what you think the wrist is
doing on the on the left hand it's the
same correction on
chis but not it doesn't make sense to
push through someone's grip do you guys
understand
that do you guys understand
that what I did not okay so his grip is
a hole
you
see and then you're going to try to push
through this
scrip that doesn't make sense cuz he can
let
go and I don't get anything or I slip
through and I lose energy do you get
that so I
get that there it
is and you want to push you want to push
through this do you see that
but that's where you're going to make
your UK
Aquabat you right he's got to make sure
I don't push through cuz he's going to
ride it and bounce and put his head
upside down do you understand do you get
that that if your Uka has to be acrobat
then the attacker is not going
to be
there okay
so then that's actually what we do to
get out of the technique we actually are
relying on that so when you're doing
this thing you're
not shoving through the grip and then he
held on you're changing you're changing
what you're doing in the
spiral you are going to
load the
elbow I'm going to exaggerate what it's
like so you see this this is what it's
like that and that happens
that happens in the grip if I stop here
I'm in the grip I have to keep turning
the wrist and the elbow into the
technique till I get akin to
that through the
grip energy
linkage his palm on my
forearm pushes through he can let go all
he wants you guys see that okay try it
again you feel the push
[Music]
Virginia it's in your palm not through
your
fingers got to get it on your forearm
Chris in his
palm we can't paint it though right
that's the obvious
mistake we going to keep our foot down
and then the bottom hand elbow comes in
and it reaches out
extend foot down
[Music]
that's not the bottom man
you're not doing the
bottom bottom
[Music]
round doesn't
stop keeps extending
out keeps extending
out this way
you're going to pin his
foot keep leading him out making him go
making him
go not pulling
him he's not chasing
me
inside KN down you pin keep making his
Center move
so this shape not
it here then it starts it's how much
further could it
go how much further so what's it need to
do in the yinong
world what around in a yinong world
what's it need to do it's reached its
completion
reverse it's got to move around on a
spiral or you have to what's it have to
do uh it's come all the way in and now
it's going to go out got it so if it
went all the way to the end of its y
phase and now enter what this y face so
if it did the end of its outward spiral
it has to enter it inward spiral okay
and not sitting here and for now I'm
forcing it you feel
that so I get
out then it's it's almost
going this way back into
the boom boom but you don't cuz you only
need it long
enough to get the balance off okay but
this isn't it that's you trying to shove
them down you trying to overpower so you
not listen to the teacher right
go better lead him with that hand
meaning you're making his Center keep
going
forward and then the forearm projects
across that at the X
make sure it's not pushing him in the
same
way get out of his
[Music]
shoulder you're painting the
obvious foot
don't don't push him with the other hand
in the same direction it's an
axe you to use your a spiral your wrist
and elbow have to rotate around each
other
[Music]
sh
change PR
say save time and uh just do the center
and move it like an inch or two so we
don't have to keep rolling
wrist and
elbow
right yeah that pace
[Music]
so you turned into C
so might as well work with it
okay
here
behind fine you're just doing the
drill we're doing I guess we're doing
you
got see that yes you
got I got you
pass because your X pow is right here
boom you see
yes otherwise I'm going to go in your
shoulder yes
okay okay but not that don't do it like
that cuz just save time I'm getting up
and down
try he's got the right Vector you can
just copy his all
shoulder don't let him pass you
pay attention to the last correction
okay don't you don't want him to pass
you if we're doing cook
Naga you if the center's past you and
you're going around the center on the
back back side you're going to end up in
the shoulder and there'll be so much
energy leakage because the other hand is
already bringing them forward okay okay
let's
go go get the spiral we still doing that
all
right you want to use your elbow in the
inside the grip not through the grip
[Music]
better he went back to Palm up on the in
hand over the top back try it again you
went over the top back
feel how goes right up right through
your palm not not on the same tunnel of
your fingers and tops all right
better for